a él
[Música]
podemos hablar del dolor
podemos describirlo
podemos imaginarlo
sin embargo
cuando el dolor se nos pone en frente
nos atraviesa de una manera inevitable
nos cambia nos transforma y se apropia
de nuestras propias decisiones
esta historia
para un día como cualquier otro en el
estudio jurídico viene carola una mamá
cargada de expectativas por un tema que
parecía uno más vinculado a la temática
del derecho de la salud y cuando pasan
los minutos aparece en carpetas informes
y aparece micaela
ante una situación de crisis y el pedido
de acceder al cannabis medicinal
porque otras niñas en el mundo habían
podido desde el cannabis medicinal
obtener soluciones mejor calidad de vida
disminuir el sufrimiento y ese fue el
pedido de la madre por supuesto que ver
una madre en una condición desesperada
sabiendo que su hija en cada crisis éste
se enfrentaba no solamente a una
situación de angustia sino también a la
posibilidad de que no vuelva en sí de
que su vida por falta de oxígeno se
ponga en peligro a partir de eso
iniciamos un camino por supuesto que
este camino que aparecía como un camino
nuevo y difícil
fue un desafío que contó con el apoyo de
la sociedad comodorense instituciones
medios de comunicación acompañan esta
necesidad de una niña y luego la
provincia mediante la legislatura del
chubut hizo una ley de cannabis
medicinal para epilepsia puesto que la
epilepsia refractaria es la enfermedad
que mika de la debía sobrellevar micaela
y su familia porque cada crisis cada
momento era la situación grave
amenazante diríamos el contacto directo
con el terror y el acompañamiento ante
la imposibilidad de llevar adelante
ninguna otra acción esta ley trataba la
cobertura del cannabis medicinal
pasaron dos años y ya la república
argentina sancionó la ley nacional de
cannabis medicinal
toda esta experiencia de contacto con la
familia significó una transformación
social pero también una transformación
personal una transformación desafiante
donde evidentemente los prejuicios
abundaban hablar de cannabis era algo
que en la sociedad se vinculaba a un
sector de la sociedad y no a los niños
que sufrían epilepsia refractarias con
cientos de situaciones semanales y con
una familia que no tenía mejor opción
que esperar que éstas pasen el cannabis
medicinal y una oportunidad de romper
prejuicios de entender que las
herramientas con las que uno cuenta
pueden significar una transformación
para la sociedad
el cannabis medicinal abrió la puerta
para una familia cambió el estado de
salud o la condición de salud de mika
pero también me transformó en primera
persona
este desafío fue no por una cuestión
legal sino por romper prejuicios por
dejar miedos porque el que dirán por una
acción no importa lo que importa es la
posibilidad de transformación la
posibilidad de ponernos en el lugar del
otro
la madre actuó porque ir a un último
recurso
eso generó una urgencia hay una
motivación extra
es importante que podamos asumir que
nuestras acciones pueden modificar
muchísimo la vida de otras personas y
sobre todo en este contexto tener en
cuenta que el dolor no puedo esperar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sí